Je ne sais pas comment être drôle Je ne sais pas
comment travailler les gens et elle
sait lire les chiffres tout le marché du logement
est soutenu par ces mauvais prêts comment savez-
vous que les obligations ne valent rien Je les
lis personne ne lit  eux, il est une force de la
nature Michael burry, il était en fait
neurochirurgien dans sa résidence et il a
démissionné parce qu'il s'ennuyait s'il vous plaît ne
me patronnez pas s'ils écoutent, il est
absolument identique
à n'importe quel gars de Wall Street j'aime ces tasses
pourrais-je en prendre un pour mon  fils oui le gars
qui écoute du speed metal la plupart du temps
ne porte pas de chaussures moi il passerait des semaines à
porter les mêmes vêtements il aime la
solitude parce qu'il est tellement plus
intelligent les interactions sociales sont
gênantes pour moi même quand j'essaie de
complimenter ça vient  avoir une très belle
coupe de cheveux l'avez-vous fait vous-même
ma femme m'a dit cette année que
vous